[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome back kevin o'leary star
of abc shark tank aka mr wonderful kevin
always good to see you great to be here
thank you so much yes it's really
interesting times in the market
just insane times right now help us
unpack it all let's start with your take
on inflation here
you know when are we going to hit peak
inflation kevin
well it we haven't yet um particularly
if this buildback batter bill uh prints
another 400 to 600 billion dollars and
flushes it right into the economy
that's probably not going to be a good
outcome for inflation because it's very
inflationary even though it's been it's
it's trying to be labeled as an
anti-inflation bill anytime you print
anytime you print money you get
inflation so we'll see what happens
that's got to go through the gauntlet in
washington that's one factor the other
that's really interesting that has
a lot of market watchers really
scratching their heads right now because
it's never happened before you've got a
situation of full employment that's like
three and three point four percent
and yet at the same time a second
quarter of gdp
shrinking
that has never happened before so one
way to interpret that is to say the
productivity of the two plus million new
workers that have just been booked into
the economy must be very very low
or maybe they're not really working
eight hours maybe they're working less
but there's something not working
to the traditional model which is why i
think it's giving powell pause
because he has been job owning a more
dovish fed having just done the 75 basis
points even he doesn't know what's
happening here so he's data dependent
we've never seen this before never never
in the history of the economy in 200
plus years has this ever occurred so
again another sign that is not fitting
with what everybody wants towards this
recession may be
okay and you say towards this recession
so i know there's a debate out there of
whether we're in it or not i'm assuming
for you we're not in it yet
well the narrative towards the soft
landing has changed so much in the last
eight weeks because just two months ago
nobody thought powell could engineer
anything like this and here we are
you you it's very hard to call this a
recession when you've got full
employment and so is this working so at
least 50 of the pundits or the market
now believes that soft landing is
possible and again a lesson learned for
everybody that thinks they can time the
market is look it happened in july
you've got maybe half of this year's
returns came in four days and so if you
weren't in the market
you didn't capture that upside and so
it's impossible to time the market you
would have never guessed july would have
been a good month but it was
absolutely and on that point you know
help us decipher this because like you
said you know we're getting this relief
rally but is it giving us a false sense
of optimism of hope
what's the truth
well the truth is in the earnings and so
far everybody was waiting to see
earnings completely blow up didn't
happen many companies delivered even the
highly speculative tech companies and
we're halfway more than halfway through
earnings season and it looks pretty good
now it's not as good as it was a year
ago but it's nowhere near as bad as
everybody was forecasting that we would
be in the height of a recession right
now and we're not and so this is a very
difficult time to make a decision
between fixed income and equities
because you've as you mentioned earlier
in the show we've got an inverted yield
curve that's generally never good but
again when you can't tell me why we have
full employment two and a half more
million people working and low
productivity then maybe you want to be a
little careful about making more
decisions about
raising rates or changing policy or
right you know raising taxes they all
sound like really bad ideas until you've
really figured out the rate the riddle
of what's going on in this economy we
don't know so my attitude is to stay
long equities uh continue at a 30
weighting in fixed income that's very
low for me usually it's 50 percent and
just wait and see what happens my names
are high quality names that provide cash
flow and distributions but it doesn't
matter what sector you pick you've been
doing quite well in the last four weeks
let me ask you then this kevin what
grade would you give a powell then do
you think he's been doing a good job
everybody likes to beat up the fed
regardless of who's in that seat but
he's been doing a really good job
because and in my view because he just
doesn't know and doesn't say that he
knows what's going to happen next so
he's trying to stay flexible
rates right now are still at historic
lows even though he's gone through
multiple rate hikes the question is now
what's next many people think well
another one is going to be at one
percent
maybe there'll be an emergency meeting
but i don't think so he's in the same
boat as everybody else trying to figure
out where are we in this recession is it
going to be maybe two or three quarters
of slower growth or no growth we haven't
really called it yet because it's so
perplexing to have this much employment
for every job you know out there in
america
that that is available there's a ton of
people that don't want it i mean you
can't hire anybody anymore which is
incredible and you know minimum wages in
california 15 bucks for service
providers maybe in the food industry you
can't get anywhere 15 bucks 21 22 23
right now so the economy is
self-adjusting there is a ton of people
that just don't seem to want to go back
to work
let me ask you this you see your long
equities i just want to hone in on some
of your other strategies we know back in
march or 20 in the crypto phase we know
how spoken you've been about
cryptocurrencies curious to get your
take on um where we are at now i had
mark you score on last week saying hey
looks like uh the bottom is in for
bitcoin how do you see it
i see bitcoin sort of testing 20 000 all
the time getting a lot of resistance
there seems to be holding the 2023 area
still very profitable for bitcoin miners
that are currently mining at about uh 7
000 per coin at scale
and so there has been a knee-jerk
reaction against bitcoin miners lately
because of esg concerns but they're also
self-correcting by getting into nuclear
and hydropower which you know is
plentiful in some countries like norway
now crypto itself desperately needs
policy it needs regulation and there was
a bill just two weeks ago that was
contemplated being pushed through not on
bitcoin
just stable coins as payment systems and
as you know that's been a very volatile
area that bill that initiative has been
stalled till september but i think
there's a 50 50 chance that we will have
policy
on
basically stable coins tied to the us
dollar and let me explain specifically
why i think it's going to happen
there is a turf war going on between the
sec and every other regulator as regards
to crypto
nfts tokens all of this stuff and so the
smart regulators the policy makers are
saying wait a second let's pick one
outcome let's just do payment systems
just like a credit card a visa card or a
money market fund which has very you
know limited flexibility in terms of
what you can hold it basically t bills
and dollar for dollar cash same thing
with a payment system like a stablecoin
if that policy comes down let's say it
gets done in september that's a signal
to the market that we're starting to
break open the logjam on policymaking
yeah and i know you've been uh you've
been seeing this for for a very long
time but specific to your holdings kevin
what's what's been your your personal
strategy with the with the cryptos with
this down period we're in have you been
adding to your position have you have
you have you stopped are you good with
what you have what's your take
no we took a hit we were at 20 and then
it grew up to 23 percent then it went
down to 16 percent of the of the
portfolio i mean it was really volatile
but i've always said
you're going to get this volatility in
an asm industry that's not regulated
because there's no institutional bid so
probably at the low we're at 15 percent
we lost you know 40 percent of the value
and now we've come back up on some
projects and they haven't all come back
at the same pace you know the big
players the big market cap names like
bitcoin like ethereum like solana like
polygon h bar you know in some cases we
double down we took advantage of the
extreme volatility and the large cap
names like eth and like bitcoin why not
add to the position uh if you're going
to stay long but you know everybody
trying to manage this space i don't care
who you are if you tell me you made
money in the last 90 days i know you're
lying you've lost money and you're just
averaging down hoping for this to climb
back up
if you'd own these positions for more
than two years you're basically in a
break-even situation so this asset class
is not correlated with anything
as people thought it's not correlated
with inflation yet but the real problem
and every time you and i talk about this
it's really a gauge on where the
institutional buyer is and right now
zero they have no bitcoin anybody that
tells you the institutions that
sovereigns own it is full of poo poo
really good thoughts kevin uh just other
uh quick items to to to talk on here
curious to get your thoughts on the
direction of the us dollar
many folks thinking the us dollar will
keep marching higher euro will keep
marching lower uh how do you see it what
path are we on
i'm in that camp that says dollars king
dollar it's going to be stronger euro is
going to probably worst case go to 80
cents i mean look they've got lots of
external issues there that we don't deal
with here we go they have the putin
factor the energy factor uh how screwed
up germany is and shutting down all its
alternative power they did that to
themselves that's a self-inflicted wound
uh the ukraine the grain situation the
market knows all these factors but it
doesn't give you confidence to stock up
on euros and you know for me the way i'm
playing it is i'm buying the top 50
european names in their local currencies
in swiss francs in euros and british
pounds because if you look at a nestle
or you you look at american tobacco or
roche half their sales in some cases
more than half are in the united states
and now you get to buy them in their
local currency at massive discounts pe
discounts and currency discounts so why
not take down a little bit of europe and
i've increased that position for me
specifically to 20
of the operating companies portfolio
europe european names mega caps big cash
flowers
selling at huge discounts everybody
hates the european zip code right now
i want to ask you about gold we've
spoken about this in the past i remember
we made major headlines when you said
your crypto your crypto location uh had
out without weighing your your gold
position um have you
added to gold as a hedge to the crypto
portfolio have you done anything with
your gold
i have i've added a little gold and i'm
using the gld which is an expensive etf
but it's liquid enough you can put
millions in in and out in an hour and
not move the market uh and and gold
bullion itself like still keep in
storage and pay for the storage but it's
look it hasn't worked either and gold
may be the canary in the bird
you know the canary in the coal mine
that basically tells you the peak
inflation has been found and and we've
seen it because so much of it is is
disruption supply chain and disruption
of food supply chains so right now uh
gold as an indicator is is not uh it's
not doing what it should be if you
really believe we're going to
hyperinflation sounds like gold is
pretty proud of powell and saying you
know what maybe he's he's got he's
engineered a soft landing because it's
not been a great asset class of late
kevin o'leary i want to get your
thoughts on the housing market now have
we popped
housing is a tough one
it's
i like you know i watch weekly housing
uh blotters
tear sheets and in some cities housing
pricing is rolling over and some it's
not
not rolling over in boston not rolling
over in miami in fact it's up in miami
why and you know anywhere
well maybe but the same thing's
happening in texas there seems to be a
bias
in housing now to states that are
pro-economy pro-business pro-low taxes
pro low regulation those are the states
of of uh texas
and and florida
montana north dakota you know
these pockets seem to have really
buoyant housing market and rental
markets
which is you've never seen that before
it used to be you know new york city and
jersey i wouldn't want to be long really
high-end real estate in new york that or
new jersey
there's an exodus out of there and you
know this is the competition of policy
and i think it's good where do we see
what the midterms are going to bring
that's going to be really really
interesting for for biden my goodness
i'm not sure he'll hold the senate even
kevin let's wrap with one of your
favorite subjects of all time watches
you are a watch aficionado so i want to
get your tape on a bloomberg report
saying the second-hand market for luxury
watches has been flooded now because we
know those crypto millionaires were
quick to go get the patex and the rolex
many of them now selling them
is it a hot market too many watches out
there what's it going to do to the price
so i've been listening to this dialogue
now for a year about how watches are
going to roll over it simply hasn't
happened because the demand for
you know watch pieces particularly the
brands of rolex fp jorn
ap
even omega recently has had a huge run
now they're off their peaks but you're
if you've owned these watches for 24
months it still outpaced the s p it
still outpaced crypto it's the best
asset class to have been in the last two
years rolex just dropped the new gmt uh
two with the the bezel on the left hand
side which is like a funky chicken thing
to do and so it's now been named the
riddler in in the aftermarket you're up
40 50 if you can get your hands on one
and that's a 2002 release so there's no
evidence at all that second hand watch
pricing is going to have a massive
correction it has gone down 14
and by the way i watch these prices
nightly i watch what's going on watches
everywhere i'm very comfortable it's
going to continue to rise and beat the
market you are an expert i know when
it's my time to get one you're the
person i'm going to call is that
is there one on your wish list
there there are um
you know i i have to admit i've i've got
to the point in my career where most of
the brands are willing to make
one-of-a-kind mr wonderfuls for me
and my policy is always i don't give me
anything for free i don't want to owe
anybody anything
i will buy the pieces but one-of-a-kind
pieces from an fp journal one of a kind
from
you know adama pique or or any of the
one-of-a-kind from any brand uh is
priceless
and my wife is always saying who's the
guy at the phillips auction house
because when you dive i don't need all
these watches i'm going to put on a huge
auction and i say to her no you're not
going to do that that guy is paul
boutros i said all these watches are
coming in my coffin with me just like
the pharaohs because i'm going to need a
really good time piece
in eternity think about it if you like
that video wait did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe